who are the bilderberg group
and why do they meet every year
what do they talk about
and why the secrecy
do they intend to rule the world
so over there the world power elite or
gathering
we all talk about a democracy that isn't
there
people want to know what's going on what
they're talking about
a global tyranny that would have made
george orwell
wince
crashed into one of the towers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
why is it that for years it was even
denied the bilderberg group even existed
there are splits among the people who
run modern capitalist societies and so
they have meetings
is the bilderberg group the true elite
that rules the world
do they manipulate presidents and
economies to their advantage and
manipulate us to believe that we have a
voice and a choice
by the time i was born both my
grandfathers had died already
but i heard many stories about them
what i gathered from these stories
is that i must believe in myself
and have principles
and that many times an idea can be more
important than oneself
i did believe in myself
and when i moved from the world of
economics
to the world of theater
i witnessed that dedicated group effort
in theater troops
is what makes an idea succeed
[Applause]
i also learned that even though i may
sometimes be romantic
i always reject any form of injustice
[Music]
it is not strange that we hear of
individuals forming groups with the
intention to hold power and rise above
the people and democracy bilderberg
group build a badge the bilderberg group
but there is one group which many people
believe is the board of directors of the
world
the bilderberg group
who are these people the billionaires
politicians bankers and european royalty
so over there the world's power elites
are gathering people want to know what's
going on what they're talking about if
we cross that police tape we'll be
arrested
for me what is said about the extra
secrecy of the group raises questions
what are they trying to hide
if they are hiding anything
but even with their strict
confidentiality we may know a few things
we know for instance that the bilderberg
meetings were initiated by prince
bernard of the netherlands in 1954
in the bilderberg hotel in holland
the meeting takes place every year in a
different place
we may also know the general topics
discussed in the meetings
and it says in the website of the group
that participants can use any
information they received in the
meetings without revealing the names of
the speakers or participants
david ike is a british journalist and a
famous conspiracy theorist who has
researched the bilderberg group and
wrote more than 20 books
can you tell me about when the
bilderberg group first met
and for what exactly
the bilderberg group uh first met in
1954 at the bilderberg hotel in easter
big holland
to understand the timing of the creation
of the bilderberg group is to understand
what world war ii was really about
wars
are used to transform
a society
the status quo was gone and you create
another and in the aftermath of world
war ii that's when the status quo was
transformed into a world structure
that's when globalization really started
to take off
and in there is the bilderberg group in
1954
which was a part of this
coordination strategy
between different countries to create
this common push in a desired direction
this is a classic organization
drawing together
uh
prominent and influential people in all
areas of
human life
politicians
some journalists
who have a golden rule you don't report
what happened at the bilderberg meeting
these are military people intelligence
people many many heads
of major global corporations and what
the bilderberg group is
is a way of bringing these people
together to form a common
policy
and
many of the people most of the people
that turn up
um
have no idea what the big goal is
and a lot of these people come and go
come and go and are never seen again
they're just
useful in in in a short space of time
but then you have others like um david
rockefeller
who has been involved in the bilderberg
group from the start henry kissinger the
same
these people spanned a whole period of
the group's existence
couldn't we say that they were or are
just some sort of a lobby group that are
protecting their interest
a lobby group for what
is the question i would have this is not
a lobby group
for a certain
company
even a lobby group for a certain
government
why is it that for years
it was even denied the bilderberg group
even existed
they are
a global elite
which were
to push human society
into the direction
of a global tyranny that would have made
george orwell
wince
[Music]
what are you thinking about
we can't just keep blaming everyone else
for everything
wrong that's happening in the world
we blame others when we feel powerless
the question is
maybe they're not a secret society and
they're just a private one
from what is written about the group it
seems they are indeed impressive in
their breath and power
but there are other powerful groups that
meet regularly like the g7 and the g20
the major difference here is that those
meetings are not secret
if the bilderberg group is indeed the
shadow world government
well
they are doing a terrible job
or maybe
they are getting exactly what they want
and is it really true that after they
discuss something in their agenda then
we see surprising effects in the real
world
there are people that find it difficult
to believe that the oil shock of 1973
could have been masterminded by the
bilderberg group as many claimed
for starters the united states secretary
of state henry kissinger
had not attended that year
[Music]
but at the press conference of the
following bilderberg meeting in 1974
the declarations of prince bernard could
raise some questions
i want to ask the american economist dr
richard d wolf about the relation
between democracy capital and the
bilderberg
i wanted to talk to you about the
bilderberg group
why do you think these people meet
regularly there are splits and
disagreements among the people who run
modern capitalist societies and one of
the big issues they disagree about
is whether or not
they really can rely
on the capitalist system and the market
to manage modern society
in a way
that allows them to keep their dominant
position their wealth their influence
and so on
there are those who believe that the
market is a fantastic institution
that if each corporation does exactly
what is most profitable for it
this will work out to be the best
possible society for everyone then there
are other corporate leaders who say that
the levels of inequality
common to capitalist societies create
severe
vulnerability
that you are going to make the mass of
people who have middle or low income
eventually
decide to use their political power they
are the majority
to use politics to undo the results of a
capitalist private economic market
system and that therefore you must take
steps to deal with that
notice
everyone is agreed among them that what
they want is capitalism to continue the
people to run the corporations continue
but
one group doesn't want to worry about
taking care of social problems and the
other group does
and so they have meetings
because
these disagreements can become explosive
do you think this group uses their
capital to overcome democracy and the
will of the people
they have no interest in democracy they
never did and let me explain why
every one of these people they operate
their enterprises
in a fundamentally
anti-democratic way
for example the board of directors does
not submit its proposals or its
strategies to the entire employees to
get their approval
that would be a democratic way to run an
enterprise they don't do that
what the enterprise is in capitalism is
a systematic training of the population
against
democracy
if you spend five days a week nine to
five at your factory or in your office
you are in an environment that teaches
you to accept orders from whoever is
above you in the hierarchy there is no
democratic control
we all talk about a democracy that isn't
there
and partly the talk is a compensation
because it isn't the reality 300 years
ago we got rid of kings but the kings
didn't go away
they were clever
they went inside the capitalist
corporation and they changed their name
it's now ceo
would you say that these kind of groups
are think tanks
or they're rather the biggest capitalist
lobby ever
i prefer the lobby because uh thinking
is is not their strong suit
uh what they do is they hire people to
do the thinking for them
i went to all the elite schools in this
country
i know all these people
they're managers that's what they've
been trained to do to manage to identify
who they can rely on who has technical
knowledge of this or that so they bring
people like me a critic of the system
they want to know how
people like me look at all of this and i
always have an ambivalent feeling
wondering to myself who am i helping
here
you know these are not my people
we are laughing but
it actually feels hopeless do you think
there is any way around this
in the heyday when they're when these
systems are powerful they are powerful
because they have persuaded the mass of
people that it must be this way
from the first time i heard stories
about my grandfathers i had a heroic and
maybe naive view of the world
as i grew up and learned more
that challenge was to keep the flame
inside me alive
to believe that i can be part of the
change
it is tempting to believe that we have
no power
that our votes don't matter
but our protests don't matter
i believe they only matter
if we ask the right questions
[Music]
so
[Music]
you